so my um you know my feeling uh I think
uh well my feeling about the use of the
word Su pseudo science is probably the
same as the majority of the community
and I now think probably the majority of
the co-authors of that open letter it
should not have been used um it was um
ungentlemanly um and inappropriate um
the motivation for it um probably um in
its sort of you know in its simplest
form was exactly to um discourage the
young PhD student from further
committing to that kind of research more
specifically to stop charitable
foundations funding that kind of
research which I think is a dangerous
and flawed um um motivation or certainly
you know um acting upon that kind of
motivation is is